[Music]
on this Wednesday night cautious moves
to relax some pandemic restrictions the
Prime Minister pleads for patience we
need to hold on
still as fears deepened for Canada's
most vulnerable and the staff who care
for them they support us and they
encourage us and they they hold it's
when we cry one provinces promised to
deploy a SWAT team of health workers the
Emergency Response benefit expands again
who else is now eligible for aid meat
production disruption the changes you
could see at the grocery store and
proving the point of physical distancing
what's behind the 2 meter rule
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
lots of developments to get you on this
Wednesday from new financial support for
Canadians to Ontario's plan to send SWAT
teams into long-term care homes hit by
outbreaks and the world has reached
another alarming milestone in this
pandemic the number of confirmed cases
worldwide has now surpassed two million
and here in Canada more than 1,000
people are now known to have died from
covin 19 and more than 28,000 people
have been infected here's a snapshot of
where things stand today more than 1300
new cases were reported across the
country Quebec and Ontario are still
seeing the biggest spikes some provinces
though have no new cases reported and
Canada's public health officer says
there's reason for cautious optimism in
late March when the growth rate was the
fastest we saw case numbers doubling
every three days but in recent days
we've observed a doubling time of over
10 days
this means the epidemic is slowing down
with early signs the curve may be
flattening there's talk in some
provinces about how to begin easing some
restrictions in Quebec some businesses
like auto mechanic shops and garden
centers were allowed to reopen today
Quebec Premier says he's working on
guidelines to allow more small
businesses to reopen soon Saskatchewan
is also working on a plan it's seen a
slowdown in new cases and Premier Scott
Moe says if that continues some
businesses will be allowed to slowly
reopen but life won't be fully back to
normal anytime soon travel large
gatherings and and our seniors care
homes we know those are three very
high-risk areas and we will not be
removing removing those restrictions in
the foreseeable future a similar plan is
being worked on in British Columbia
premier John Horgan extended that
provinces state of emergency today but
he says progress has been made in
slowing the spread there and talks are
underway to start easing restrictions
including potentially restarting
classroom education in the
not-too-distant future I look at my
colleagues across the country who set
arbitrary dates for a return before the
data was in before the
science was confirming that and we're
not going to follow that lead we're
going to look at the numbers as they
emerge over the weeks ahead before we
make those determinations in Nova Scotia
we're 32 new cases were reported today
officials say they're still weeks away
from any talk of reopening let me be
clear we're not there so before anyone
communicates to Nova Scotians that we're
now going to open up in the two weeks or
three weeks we have we're not there
we need Nova Scotia stay committed to
following the public health orders Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau is talking with
the Premier's about all of this there
are many regional differences and he's
warned Canadians it's going to be a long
slow process and right now we can't give
up keeping physically distant and
slowing the spread it seems like over
the past days people are talking about
when we reopen this will do this will
reopen that it's not happening
yet if we reopen too soon everything
we're doing now might be for nothing we
are making sacrifices we're there for
each other we need to hold on still
there is still a crisis unfolding inside
long-term care homes where at least half
the deaths from kovat 19 have happened
Ontario's premier says SWAT teams of
health care workers will be sent to
homes overwhelmed by outbreaks Quebec's
premier has appealed to doctors and
nurses for help and today Prime Minister
Trudeau says he will talk to the
Premier's about boosting the wages of
long-term care workers as we face an
unprecedented threat to public health
you are our most important line of
defence we will do whatever we can to
help you do your job and support you
through this time and as Ross Lord
reports lawyers say families with loved
ones in long-term care reaching out to
them looking for help some asking how
they can sue the homes at this nursing
home in Toronto more than 20 residents
have died from Kovan 19 the higher the
death toll at care homes rises in Canada
the more families fear victims like 89
year old Phyllis Thompson will be
forgotten I didn't want her to just
be a statistic that there's another one
British Columbia and Alberta already
limited staff to working at just one
care home at a time now Ontario's
followed suit the province promises an
immediate influx of personal protective
equipment and a SWAT team style shift of
staff from hospitals to nursing homes
that's being rolled out as we speak over
the next 24 to 48 hours it's already
happening regionally in some areas we
are going to make sure that that happens
across the board in Quebec the
government is pleading with doctors to
come and support nursing home staff the
premier has already suggested soldiers
might be required
he now promises to investigate a double
standard surrounding criminal background
checks this after two newspapers
reported on the past criminal record of
the president and co-owner of a home
where more than 30 people have died in
the past month his family says he was
pardoned I've asked my people to check
out come we have some background checks
for employees but not for owners taking
care of elderly so that's why I was
surprised to it to hear that the gaps in
long-term care exposed by the virus
become more tragic by the day and they
become more frightening especially in
provinces like Nova Scotia which has the
highest proportion of seniors in Canada
if you put a system that's already
struggling already understaffed already
underfunded and then say could you just
could you do some more because we've got
this struggle in front of us
well our staff only have so much to give
and they're giving it there are growing
questions about safety culture and tario
has reportedly made deep cuts to full
inspections and the union that
represents nursing home staff says
operators get advanced notice of
inspectors arrival so they can give the
appearance homes are in better shape
than they actually are
now class-action lawyers say families
are contacting them about suing
long-term care homes ensuring this
tragic episode will go on in various
ways for a long time
Ross Laura Global News Halifax more
financial help is coming for Canadians
who didn't qualify when the Canada in
emergency-response benefit was first
rolled out the CRB is being expanded now
to include part-time seasonal and
contract workers as well as anyone whose
employment insurance recently ran out my
click at Ora has the details it would be
like Christmas not happening for a
retailer that's big as a self-employed
artisan the countrywide shut down means
Meghan Rose Babb has no one to buy the
jewelry and accessories she crafts my
hand she nearly had to dip into her line
of credit but then she was given a
lifeline we are expanding the Canada
emergency response benefit to include
people making up to $1,000 a month
seasonal workers and people whose AI has
recently run out it applies to part-time
workers volunteer firefighters and
people like Meghan makes a lot of
difference to me because now I know that
I can pay my mortgage I can pay my bills
by food the CRB has meant a lot to a lot
of Canadians in the first week of its
rollout the benefits saw nearly three
and a half million applications
anyone who has applied for employment
insurance before that time was
automatically put in the CRB stream
pushing the total number of applications
for help dating back to March 15th -
nearly six million Canadians according
to the government they've processed 90%
of those claims the NDP is claiming a
victory saying they helped push the
government to include more categories of
workers than the Liberals originally
planned still jug meat Singh says many
more need help
especially students we need people to
stay at home then we're asking students
to go out and apply for a job that
doesn't seem to be in line with what the
public health experts are saying the
prime minister says help will be coming
for post-secondary students later this
week but it's unclear if they too will
be allowed to apply for the CRB and on
that government officials are reminding
people have already received the benefit
that because a new pay period is about
to start they have to contact the
government to
reapply or reconfirm that they're still
eligible for the benefit Donna all right
Mike thanks the American President
Donald Trump is facing criticism for his
decision to suspend funding to the World
Health Organization he blames the w-h-o
for not doing enough to stop the corona
virus and for being too lenient on China
where it all started the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation is the next
biggest donor to the w-h-o after the US
and in a tweet Bill Gates said halting
funding for the World Health
Organization during a world health
crisis is as dangerous as it sounds
their work is slowing the spread of
kovat 19 and if that work has stopped no
other organization can replace them the
world needs the w-h-o now more than ever
and today the head of the US Centers for
Disease Control said this you know I
just going to say that w-h-o has been
and a long-standing partner for CDC
we've worked together and to fight
health crisis all around the world we
continue to do that because the w-h-o
isn't just fighting ko bid 19 it works
with other diseases that need desperate
attention to Jackson prosecco reports
the huge cut and funding could be
disastrous we regret the decision of the
President of the United States this was
not a battle the World Health
Organization was prepared for not in the
middle of a global pandemic the w-h-o
failed in this basic duty and must be
held accountable but as Co vid 19 cases
and deaths surge in the United States
President Donald Trump has started
looking for someone to blame he's
targeting the w-h-o by slashing funding
and using his office to launch a smear
campaign the delays the w-h-o
experienced in declaring a public health
emergency cost valuable time we alerted
the world in January the fifth systems
around the world including the u.s.
began to activate their incident
management systems on January the 6th on
January 23rd the WHL warned cases may
appear in any country thus all countries
should be prepared for containment
shortly after Trump praised their work
for the World Health Organization
a lot of them are composed of our people
they're fantastic that was before the
president faced criticism for his own
failure to act on those warnings when
the US could have rolled out proven
testing and stocked up on medical
supplies the World Health Organization
is not responsible for that slow
response again other countries received
the same information responded a lot
earlier the u.s. provides nearly half a
billion dollars to the w-h-o about 15
percent of the total budget the agency
focuses largely on work in developing
countries that are ill-prepared to
tackle the pandemic on their own the
World Health Organization is not like
the United States government where we
can go into debt it's an organization
that has to have money to kind of keep
its efforts going despite warnings that
have failure to control the outbreak in
any country will have dire consequences
for every country the Trump
administration seems undeterred pressing
ahead with the fight against those
fighting the virus
Jackson prosecco Global News Washington
some of Canada's less busy US border
crossings are about to become even more
quiet because of Kovach 19 the Canada
Border Services Agency is temporarily
cutting hours at 27 locations in BC
Alberta Manitoba Saskatchewan and Quebec
the changes which won't impact
commercial traffic take effect tonight
and will remain in effect until further
notice you can find the full list of the
affected crossings and their new hours
on our website Global News CA / global
national changes are also expected at
the supermarket soon coming up what
could be missing from the meat
department bust parade during a pandemic
105 reasons to celebrate a war veteran
you
[Music]
one of the many sectors hit by this
pandemic is meat processing as employees
in plants test positive some are closing
and that's affecting supply lines
especially for pork and beef david aiken
explains the impact at the grocery store
the Smithfield pork processing plant in
South Dakota accounts for nearly five
percent of America's pork processing
capacity it went offline indefinitely
this week Canada's biggest pork producer
Ollie mount has also lost significant
processing capacity and in Calgary
Cargill has slashed production at a
meatpacking plant that accounts for 40
percent of Canada's beef production all
of it because of workers sick with Kovan
19 so a smell ative Lee small number of
these factories processed a huge
proportion of the meat in Canada and the
US and so if one of those goes down it
has a huge ripple effect across the
entire industry and actually really
threatens that entire supply chain and
that ripple effect will reach consumers
we might have some challenges in terms
of variety we're not facing a massive
food security crisis as a result but I
don't think that it will be as easy or
as cheap to buy beef and pork in the
next month or two as it has
traditionally been back at the farm some
producers are now stuck with hundreds of
thousands of growing animals that still
need to be fed southern Ontario hog
farmer Stewart Skinner is okay for now
but he's worried about the future
vaccine strategy some hogs are going to
food banks others are being butchered
and sold at the farm gate
worst case scenario some may have to be
euthanized and the trick is to do
everything we can to build in
flexibility and create a more robust
supply chain up and down from the farm
gate right down to the grocery store
Ottawa is trying to keep the production
line moving freeing up twenty million
dollars to hire more meat inspectors and
negotiating to drop restrictions on
enter provincial meat exports David
Aitken Global News Ottawa
I had the ninety nine year old raising
millions with every step
the european union has revealed a
roadmap to phase-out some restrictions
that you says all actions should be
gradual and monitored internal border
controls should be lifted in a
coordinated manner and the restart of
economic activity should be phased in
gatherings should be progressively
permitted but efforts to prevent the
spread of the virus should remain
Denmark has partially reopened schools
after a month-long lockdown children up
to the age of eleven are returning to
some nurseries and schools Denmark was
one of the first countries in Europe to
lock down and it is the first to lift
restrictions on schools but strict
hygiene measures are in place desks have
been moved six feet apart and recess is
staggered to limit large groups
thousands of parents are wary though
they kept their kids at home the number
of new cases in Denmark has been on the
decline for the past several days New
Zealand's Prime Minister says if there
was ever a time to close the pay gap it
is now so Jacinda are durn and other top
government officials are taking a 20%
pay cut for the next six months the
country is under full lockdown and are
durn says the pay cut is McNall agent of
the hit many New Zealanders are taking
we feel acutely the struggle that many
New Zealanders are facing and so to to
the people that I work with on a daily
basis and while it in itself won't shift
the government's overall fiscal position
it is about leadership
a British veteran who is 99 years old
found his own way to show leadership and
the response has been bigger than he
ever imagined retired captain Tom Moore
set out to walk 100 laps around his
garden by his 100th birthday which is
April 30th he hoped to raise 1,000
British pounds for the NHS the British
Health Service but his walks have been a
smash hit and he's already raised over
10 million pounds and he'll give every
penny
to those fighting the coronavirus at all
times they're so good so cheerful so
friendly and when the third now if you
look at this way said we're to follow
comms
purchase favors are brave and that's
what they are they're brave you know
bless him and he says the medical
professionals helped him through a hip
surgery in cancer now it's his chance to
thank them and once he's reached 100
laps he intends to keep right on going
two metres or not two metres next the
questions facing one rule of physical
distancing
we all know the rules now try to keep at
least 2 meters or 6 feet away from other
people if the virus can't reach you it
can infect you but what's behind that 2
meter rule researchers at Western
University and London Ontario looked
into that question in a study about the
seasonal flu and the results are raising
concerns about the transmission of kovat
19 Jeff simple explains it's become a
golden rule of the kovat 19 pandemic
please stay at least 2 meters apart from
others staying 2 meters or 6 feet apart
to slow the spread but a new study
suggests your cough can travel even
further than we thought we feel 6 feet
is not sufficient and you want to be
more precautionary researchers at this
Ontario University built a coffee ember
and asked patients with the seasonal flu
to coffin to the cube the study found
that even if you're standing 6 feet or
about 2 meters away from someone who
then coughs in your direction around 10%
of the cough droplets will reach you in
about 3 seconds and some of those
droplets will then travel even further
one study at MIT found that particles
from a cough can travel up to 16 feet
however the bigger the distance the
smaller the viral dose meaning the
droplets are less likely to make you
sick cause each droplet also has a
weight so what happens is that the heavy
ones fall to the ground really quickly
but coughing and sneezing are not the
only causes for concern
I think the jewelry still out on whether
coffin 19 can spread through aerosols
there's no indication that Kovan 19 can
travel long distances like measles but
there is growing evidence the virus can
spread through speaking even breathing
and linger in the air one example 45
members of this church choir in the u.s.
became infected even though none had any
symptoms and all were avoiding physical
contact if it's open to a friend who's
had garlic or curry or a drink over
lunch for example if you can smell that
curry garlic or alcohol
breath you're close enough to inhale any
virus they might be exhaling and the
longer the exposure the greater the risk
an infected person talking for five
minutes in a poorly ventilated space can
produce as many viral droplets as one
cough experts say it underscores the
importance of other safety measures like
ensuring proper ventilation and wearing
masks
while also keeping your distance Jeff
sample Global News Toronto and that is
global national for this Wednesday I'm
Donna freeze and we leave you tonight
with a birthday that deserved a parade
Burnett Thomas Sisler turned 105 this
weekend word spread about his milestone
about 50 vehicles drove by honking and
hooting tuition well bird as he's known
as one of Canada's oldest surviving
veterans of the Second World War he has
11 grandchildren 19 great-grandchildren
and nine great-great grandchildren
happy birthday bird
you